this is your reminder that the BBC has
yet to address the consistent
transphobic leanings in its news
coverage and while the team behind
Doctor Who is not connected to this in
any way since this is a BBC owned
property I'm going to keep pointing it
out until the problem gets resolved
links in a pin comment below if you
don't know what I'm talking about I'll
stop saying it when it stops being a
problem I put a video out two days ago
to catch up on Doctor Who's
stuff
and
[Music]
[Applause]
then I swear they do this to me on
purpose the day before my catch up with
my thoughts on Doctor Who stuff but the
day before that video comes out the
children of need special comes out and I
I didn't think that was going to be a
problem I thought like I rarely have too
many thoughts about these if I have
anything to say I'll just I'll do it as
a short or maybe I'll throw something up
in the break room and then the day my
last video went out the discourse
exploded
over the children in needs special so
here we are again they do this to me on
purpose to screw up my schedule I swear
they do I know they don't really I'm
just venting okay so the 2023 children
in need Doctor Who special I believe
it's now gotten the official uh
designation of
destination um uh Scaro I couldn't think
of the planet all of a sudden Destin
destination Scaro you can see this thing
has already scrambled my brain looking
at all this and thinking about it and
seeing the conversations going on on
we've got a lot to talk about and we are
going to spend the most on this talking
about the discourse that has come up
around the depiction of Davos and in
particular in regards to what Russell T
Davis said about the way davus is
depicted in this and we will get to that
and I can pretty much guarantee it will
make up the bulk of this video but
before we do that let's actually just
talk about the short in and of itself
separate from that whole conversation
all right this is taking an approach not
unlike the first um children of needs
special of the what had been the modern
era of Doctor Who what what was
eventually designated Born Again dealing
with tenant immediately following the
Regeneration sort of serving as an in
between that and the Christmas Invasion
this kind of does the same thing not
really serving the same purpose because
it's not you know further selling the
idea of um regeneration or things which
that one kind of had to do but it is
taking that kind of placement this is
the first place that David tenant's 14th
doctor shows up following the
Regeneration before he gets to wherever
he was actually trying to get to and
presumably where the uh special that we
are getting very soon will
start
but uh the where he ends up not only
happens to be Scaro of course Dolex got
to have him shows up at a
time not technically before the Dole
exist but slightly earlier than he's
ended up there for and in specific Davos
has not yet undergone the event in his
life that will leave him scarred blinded
and using a life support uh mobile
system to get around and still be alive
so we get Davos as still portrayed by
Julian bleach so we have consistency in
the performer and he is showing the
latest version of the dollx though they
haven't been named yet and we have kind
of an assistant he almost seems like
he's they don't call him this but it
seems like they've got a guy from Mark
to help sell the idea of the dos and
he's like well we could we should call
them something that's an anagram of Ked
and he starts going through all these
options and you know doesn't come to do
but Davos is just like no no and when
Davos unveils this thing puts a big
emphasis on the multi-use claw which is
there in place of the plunger we're used
to seeing well Davos goes out um the
doctor the Tardis comes in crashes I'm
giving you the full context in case you
missed it haven't seen it you should
it's easy to see it's on the do YouTube
channel but like let's go over the cont
text the doctor breaks off the arm comes
out like sees it calls it a dialect the
guy writes it down the doctor realizes o
i shouldn't be here this is bad this
isn't great has a little bit of banter
and tosses the guy a toilet plunger
which he sticks on the arm Davos comes
back sees that it's replaced what he had
there and basically goes I love it I
like
it so I don't really care for this not
because because of the reasons of all
the discourse my thoughts on that are
more complicated and we'll get to them
but just like as a thing I've never
really cared for too much of this kind
of thing it's kind of the same reason I
have a not a high degree of enjoyment of
a lot of the Christmas specials it's the
more jokey tone like I don't have a
problem with Doctor Who being jokey but
there's a very specific way to do it at
least that sits right with me
particularly if they're going to be
making jokes about the standard content
of the show itself to put it another way
the jokes being made in this like the
idea of what if what if you know they
were coming up with all these different
things and it took them a while to come
up with do like that's a joke that I
could laugh at if it was being made by
fans if it was being made on a panel at
a convention but having it be released
as part of actual Doctor Who media
produced professionally it's not as
funny this has to just do with another
aspect of comedy there's the joke in a
vacuum but there's also who's telling
the joke cuz that's does impact things
the same joke delivered by two different
people impacts the context of what that
joke means and speaking strictly
personally when shows like Doctor Who
where part of the charm is that they
take a lot of absurdity pretty seriously
like occasionally a little joke a little
gag but for the most part they take what
goes on seriously to start poking fun at
itself the way the fans might when
talking amongst each
other it kind of takes the fun out of it
some thing about when one of these
things that's easy to make fun of which
doctor who is tries to be in on the joke
it just it it sits wrong it has that
feel of a of a boss or like a principal
at a school like being self-deprecating
to get in good with everybody and it
just it it just doesn't land right for
me so I just I don't like this and that
just has to do with my own preferences
and like I can handle Doctor Who you
know poking fun and like drawing
attention to things that like that's one
of the things I actually liked about
Bill but the difference between Bill and
this is Bill was asking certain
questions you know and making
observations about the Tardis it's like
a spaceship
kitchen what a really Posh kitchen the
door money felt slightly jokey but it
was actually part of the dynamic she had
with the doctor as a companion doctor
pear because she was asking questions
and looking at things and approaching
things from a not not only a different
way than he thought but a different way
than he was used to and that was a
actual part of their Dynamic whereas
here this isn't about being part of a
dynamic this is just making the joke
more in a vacuum and since it doesn't
have a greater context to fit into like
a companion doctor Dynamic it just
doesn't sit well with me like it's it's
fine it's fine if you like this I mean
also keep in mind I don't even really
like um curse of the Fatal death so I've
been called a party pooper for that
alone and that might cause you to feel
my opinion on Doctor Who related comedy
is just invalid in the first place fair
enough if you liked it found it funny
that's fine seeing David Tenant as this
doctor it really does just feel like the
10th doctor to be fair this is a very
brief appearance not really enough to go
by I still really would have liked it if
they'd let him use his natural Scottish
accent for then I think that would have
been a great way to just distinguish the
14th and 10th like super easily Beyond
whatever specifics of the
characterization do or don't happen will
end up seeing but certainly just hearing
him come out hearing that voice it just
it feels like the 10th doctor again
which isn't what I'm here for I want to
see what he does different with it but
again I can't really judge that for
what's going to happen in the specials
based off that so my overall thoughts on
the special as a
special it's fine it's like it's
children are need special and by and
large
those they're just there for fun like
some of them can be good I like time
crash I like that one quite a bit but
like I don't need this to be that
massive or life-changing or like the
best thing I've ever seen like it's a
thing it's for fun it's for charity it's
fine okay so the
discourse this pretty much all centers
around Davos and the fact that Davos is
depicted not in his traditional look not
scarred not blinded not in the chair
so Russell T Davis went record saying
that part of the reason to decide to do
this was to address the issue that Davos
plays into some very unfortunate tropes
uh that are incredibly common and have
been for a long time of people with
disabilities and specifically people who
make use of Mobility AIDS like
wheelchairs which DAV Ro's life support
thing effectively is that having them be
not only villains but incredibly evil
villains it's kind of a harmful Trope I
had put problems with that and a lot of
us on the production team had the
problems with that of associating
disability with evil and trust me
there's a very long tradition of this on
bare premise of that statement yes it is
I agree it is a harmful Trope davus does
play into it I've actually talked about
disability representation before and I
and a whole section of that video was on
disabled uh characters as villains you
can check that video out there I'm not
going to reference it but that'll give
you some context for you know my overall
thoughts on this kind of thing so Bare
Bones I agree davus has historically
played into that now what I think is
really worth pointing out before we get
into some more of what he said I know
what it was we'll get to it but this has
been set up so that it is not
technically an alteration of cannon in
regards to Davos and his use of uh the
mobility Aid or of his scarring because
it is set at an earlier time before that
would have happened that's made
incredibly clear so while the decision
to depict dvos this way does seem to
have been primarily rooted in a desire
to address the Trope it has not actually
talking within the confines of the
special it has not actually
altered his being his his existence it
is simply put the focus on a point in
time when those problematic things
aren't yet part of his
character however Russell T Davis did
have other things to say too I'm not
blaming people in the past at all but
the world changes and when the world
changes Doctor Who has to change as well
we can evolve we can start a new broadly
speaking I agree with this statement as
a general philosophical operating
principle I agree Doctor Who should
evolve it's a malleable show it's
possibly the most malleable long-running
property ever just because of the nature
the re the rejuvenating nature of
regeneration so I agree with that and
then he said this is how we see Davos
now like this is 2023 this is our lens
this is our eye things used to be black
and white they're not in black and white
anymore and Davos used to look like that
and he looks like this now so this is
all kind of money the way he said this
it certainly can be interpreted
as Davos whenever we see him going
forward will be like this and we will
not see him in the chair again now I'm
not necessarily going to um accept that
as the reading my own personal take on
this we'll still deal with all the
discourse but my own personal take on
this is that I expect that he either
does not intend to depict Davos again
and he wants this image to be the most
current image of him or that if he's
going to the bck D again he's going to
pull something from this point in time I
don't think he intends to alter Davos so
that it's a case of like well Davos has
finally had his scars healed and
everything so now he's just walking
around even though this is the point in
time after all that stuff happened
nothing about what he said to me
indicates that that is the case however
that is a potential read on it and again
to come back to another part of what he
said with the intent of this another
thing that I do agree with broadly
speaking that if you were going to show
a character like
Davos having him not be in the chair and
not be massively visibly
scarred that's a good call if you're
going to use him in a children in need
special it's children in need night it's
a night where issues of disability or
otherness or being excluded from Society
come right to the front of the
conversation I agree with that although
I would caveat with the question okay so
why use Davos at all why not just have
like some other CED Commander referenced
say this is DAV Ross's latest thing and
have the punchline not be Davos going I
love it but have the the commander type
person being like oh maybe he'll maybe
he'll buy it with the plunger like you
you didn't need to actually insert him
in here for the jokes to work by and
large so while I agree with him that if
you're going to put Davos in a children
in need special yeah you should probably
do this and again moving the timeline
allows him to do that without
technically altering Canon although it's
some people are pointed out the doctor
kind of mentions that time is being
messed with which is another thing
giving people some concern that this is
going to be used to rewrite um so that
maybe now the version of history is that
Davos never ended up in the chair I was
never over here never the time lines in
the cannon are rupturing I'm just going
to go again I don't believe that to be
the case it is possible we just have to
wait and see as far as that goes but
while I agree that if you're doing the
children need special and you have Davos
this is the better way to do it you
didn't have to put him in there so it
seems very much like the intent of
putting him in there was kind of as a
statement if not on the character
possibly a little bit of an overall
statement of purpose of what Russell T
Davies intends to do with the show
overall in terms of addressing some
things that have been issues in the past
and of course naturally the harshest
read on that from certain out outrage
Merchants is that this is super going
woke and he has signaled that he plans
to make everything political Ally
correct and cater to sjws and like look
Russell T Davis has always been a
progressive guy and he has been standing
by a lot of PR Progressive causes
especially lately so I don't actually
think this is that far out of the realm
of the kind of adjustments he already
made it's just
been what uh 18 years since the launch
of the last time he ran Doctor Who his
thoughts on these things have changed
further evolved further and he wants to
change the show with them now if you
don't like that okay but I don't think
that this type of thing is that far off
from the kind of stuff he's always done
with the
show
but that leaves us with this overall
notion of should we be changing these
characters because again D didn't even
need to be here so the fact that you put
him here and chose to change him seems
to indicate that the reason you put him
there was to make the change and again
if you're going to do this as a
statement doing it as a statement on
child on children in need I understand
that do I agree with
it okay well it's complicated so let's
talk about the general notion of dealing
with problematic Legacy characters which
is something that not only Doctor Who
but lots of media has to deal with when
it comes to something that's been
running a long time and there are tropes
that have been around that as a society
we either have or should move move on
from because that's not really okay
anymore I mean whether you like either
version um that's your own personal call
but this was why I think rather
understandably the MCU has had two
different cracks at the character of The
Mandarin cuz the traditional version of
that
character not really
okay not not not going to fly uh these
days so having to do something if you're
still going to use them yeah you kind of
have to I mean overall when it comes to
these kind of altered characters Legacy
characters to my way of thinking there's
three approaches to take um when trying
to address something like this because
again to be clear the Trope that
davies's um highlighted of um disabled
people particularly wheelchair users
being villainous is it is a problem it
is a long running Trope and it's not
restricted to Doctor Who but Doctor Who
Davos in particular has fallen into it
not even only Davos you have uh
characters like the inventor of the the
cybus men the alternate reality version
of the Cybermen that was introduced in
series 2 he's kind of got the same thing
going on and that was done under
davies's tenure so heck he might want to
kind of make up for that for all I know
but that's getting into like trying to
psychoanalyze him and I don't want to do
that so as I said there's three ways to
deal with a character like this where
something core to them be it visual
characterization whatever but something
core to the character is a problem now
and or you know either is a problem or
the degree to a problem that it has
become is in excess of the narrative
value like the damage of continuing to
perpetuate this Trope this um you know
whatever it might be this Trope this
cliche whatever it is the damage is more
than the narrative benefit whether or
not DAV has crossed that line is not a
conversation I want to have I don't know
he does play into the trobe that's not
questioned has he does continue to use
him as he's traditionally been depicted
does that cause more damage than there
is value in bringing him back I don't
know but let's for the moment set aside
the question of whether or not Davos has
crossed that line let's acknowledge that
the line exists and let's talk in the
abstract for a bit so forget we're even
talking Davos just broadly speaking you
have a character that a major part of
them that's baked into the character and
has been there for a long time doesn't
really play anymore so here's the three
options you can retire the character
just stop using them alog together how
viable that is generally has to do with
how long has the character been around
and how ingrained into the um the
property are they so like a character
that had been around for 10 years and it
appeared sporadically yeah you could
probably retire that and it wouldn't be
that big of an issue a character who's
been around for more like 50 years and
has appeared pretty regularly that's
going to be harder to just outright
retire but that is an option to Simply
retire the character the second option
which is what Russell T Davis has gone
with at least within the confines of
this special again we don't know if
davus will appear again and I'm not here
to speculate on whether or not he will
if he does we'll talk about it but you
alter them in some way to address the
thing that's the problem so how viable
this is depends incredibly on the
specifics in the case of a character
like Davos the problem being the uh
enforcement of othering and villainizing
people with clear visible
disabilities yeah that's hard to undo
again I think for the purposes of the
special they found a way that within
doctor who fits but if they were to
alter him like alter the timeline or
have him find some way to repair his
body enough that he's back to he used to
be or whatever that would be a version
of this second option where you just
change the character in a way to try and
eliminate the problem this is really
hard to do again especially if the
character's been around for a long time
and if the thing that is kind of
problematic about them is very much tied
into how people think of them and kind
of the iconography of them um it is
worth pointing out that as far as
fitting into the Trope overall davus is
not great but he's not the worst cuz the
worst version of this Trope often have a
character where their disability or
anger over their disability or trying to
reverse their disability is actually the
cause of their villainy again I talked
about that in the video that I made
davus isn't really that actually the
special itself makes very clear davus is
already a terrible person he's already
making the dos and this is all bad well
before the the stuff that happens to him
that will put him in the condition we're
used to seeing him so this does benefit
in a little way in that it makes it
clear that his disability did not make
him villainous cuz there are cases where
that kind of is the case so there is
that but it is still again feeding into
the Trope even if it's not feeding into
the absolute worst version of that Trope
like I said it's difficult it is
difficult to make these kinds of changes
and it also doesn't help that trying to
update these things at a surface level
sort of looking at it from the outside
it's going to look pretty similar to
trying to update a character to have
them be hip and cool and what and what
people want these days and have it just
feel like updating character
superficially now I'm not going to say
that that's what it is when you try and
update a character to deal with
problematic elements but it can appear
that way and it can have bleed over and
cross over with those kinds of things
where it's like well if we're changing
the character anyway let's also alter
these things and then suddenly it's to
the point we're like why didn't we just
make a different character this isn't
really the same person anymore but that
is the second option is to try and
change them to address the problem then
there's the third option which is my
preferred version of solving this
problem have counter examples if you
don't have many have more if you don't
have any get some and by counter
examples I mean people embodying a
similar thing to what the villain is in
this case visible disability and have
them be a positive example instead of
having the villains be the most
prominent thing because Doctor Who has
not had a lot of disability
representation outside of a character
like Davos there's been some on occasion
we've had woff characters there was Cass
in the the fisher king Tarter and she
was defin that actually made for some
really great scenes some really tense
scenes but she was a one-time appearing
character there was Ryan with his
dyspraxia during jod Whitaker's era
unfortunately the depiction of that was
very inconsistent and also it's an inv
visible disability meaning that you
wouldn't know he had this ability unless
he said so as opposed to an immediately
evident invisible disability such as
using a Mobility Aid or um or having a
visible hearing aid or something of that
nature which doctor who hasn't really
done and honestly I would far prefer
that rather than go we need to eliminate
this villain who makes use of a Mobility
Aid you introduce a companion that does
have some counter examples have positive
instances
because just scrapping one of the few
regularly appearing uh visibly disabled
characters that's got its own problems
and I'm going to talk about some of the
responses to this in a little bit as I
said there's a lot to go over we're
still kind of talking in the abstract
largely right now but I think in general
that's the better thing to do I don't
think eliminating
representation is the solution to my way
of thinking the best way and then this
is me and talking broadly
philosophically if you're dealing with
bad representation yes maybe try and fix
it but if you can't the least you can do
is have it so the bad representation is
not the only representation you've got I
think there' be far less of a feel of a
feeling that you should change Davos if
there were significant important
recurring loved characters within Doctor
Who who used Mobility AIDS who who had a
hearing aid who are visually impaired
and maybe make use of uh of the of the
stick that um people with severe
blindness will make use of any any
number of things and anyone who tells
you that like well that would impact the
writing yeah it would make for different
things things we haven't seen before new
Dynamics New Opportunities you could
really do something interesting and
different with that to have a companion
like that and if you want some uh
interesting takes on this there's a Tik
tocker I'm going to recommend to you his
name is bowon and he is a deaf actor and
he has a number of things on his Tik Tok
talking and including doctor who talking
about both comedic and dramatic
possibilities of introducing disabled
specifically deaf cuz it's what his
wheelhouse is but talking about the
possibilities of introducing a deaf
character into things like Doctor Who
what am I doing I'm looking up a Metals
speakers cuz if I can't use my ears
nobody else can't I'm just saying if we
used BSL more often we'd probably be
captured less one it's going to be
really funny to they don't know how to
operate without their hearing I
do and they're fun and interesting and I
honestly recommend checking them out
like I said uh link down in the
description cuz yeah there's legitimate
possibilities we don't have to take
everything away we could add we could
yes and this or honestly you could do a
blend of these things you could make
some alterations to the character but
not have to completely feel the need to
undo all problematic elements cuz you're
also introducing positive counter
examples of representation this is kind
of what I talked about a few weeks ago
when I talked about the best way to get
better representation is just to have
more of it because that way if there is
sufficient representation it means that
if one of these representations is bad
that's not the only one there you can go
okay that kind of feeds into some
negative tropes but then we've got this
character who very clearly does so that
helps and it makes it feel more like um
you know we've just got an
acknowledgement that yeah anybody can be
a bad person anyone can be a good person
because we've got examples of each that
would have been my preference but
obviously that does not appear to be
what he did
so the
discourse I'm not going to deal with the
outrage Merchants I acknowledged them
briefly earlier I'm not dealing with
them what I will say and this is kind of
important the disabled community and dis
disabled Doctor Who fans are not a
monolith and not agreed on this there
are some who feel kind of insulted
almost infantilized a little bit like
what you think I can't handle a villain
having some superficial relations to me
I make use of a wheelchair he makes use
of a wheelchair suddenly I'm not okay
with him being a villain you don't have
to protect me what are you doing there's
responses like that and then there are
responses very much more in support of
this idea of making this alteration to
add address the fact that yeah this is
by far the most prominent visibly
disabled character on Doctor Who and
he's the embodiment of freaking evil
that's not great so the reason I'm
acknowledging this is because you can't
point to the disabled community and say
they think this because they think
different things they're not a monolith
crazy notion I've also seen some places
where people are like well you know he
only kind of really emphasized the idea
in the interview Russell T Davis did and
interviews aren't
Canon that's true um because within the
confines of the episodes it's just like
it's a further point back in time and
nothing about the episode indicates that
this is how we'll be seeing DAV from now
on the only reason we have anybody
believing that is because of what
Russell T Davis said and yeah interviews
aren't Canon and I do absolutely believe
that because there are things that
Russell D Davis himself has said in
interviews that I do not accept as Canon
the big one being who the woman was in
the end of time he says it was the
doctor's mother no and not just because
of what's gone on since then with tech
and the time Shi No even long before
that I rejected that idea I don't like
that idea so it is important to me that
within that show I can decide who she is
I think she's Romana by the way um and
Davis can say what he intended her to be
but it's not in the show it's not canon
interviews aren't Canon the show is
Canon and I mean Doctor Who Canon is
Lucy goosey anyway but at the very least
we need to agree on that base level so
it is true interviews aren't Canon but
interviews can indicate
intentionality and that can matter again
especially if Davos is a character who's
going to come back which we don't
know but it does seem to give an
indication of what davus would do if he
does bring davus back and again the
narrative specifics of how that may or
may not work would just be speculative
at this point um but while it is true
that interviews in and of themselves are
not canon they can give us an indication
of what is intended and I think that
Russell T dav's intention I think his
heart was very much in the right place
with this I think he wanted to undo
something that he saw as harmful and to
bring about something he saw as being
more positive and I can respect
that but also a bit like his decision to
not have David Tennant regenerate into
jod Whitaker's costume for the sake of
not having it result in a bajillion
headlines about having the returning man
as the doctor in quote unquote women's
clothes while I understand his desire to
avoid that and therefore he had the
clothes regenerate uh along with the
rest of the doctor given the the tone of
stuff going on in the UK right now in
regard to any kind of gender bendy trans
positive representation whatever I
understand the desire to avoid that and
much like there as here I think that is
a noble goal an understandable goal I
also don't really think it was the best
way to go about that I understand the
desire and intention and like I don't
want to get sidetracked on the whole
thing with jod Whitaker's costume cuz
like I've seen whole side arguments over
like well the outfit was kind of gender
neutral anyway and like let's not kid
ourselves if they had just had David
Tenant show up in her outfit there is
definitely a whole ton of people both
online and in the news over in the UK
that would have made an absolute stink
about it that would have happened
Justified or not it just would have I
personally would have preferred that he
just stand his ground and go yeah yeah
he's in her clothes what's the problem
um but he didn't and I kind of
personally speaking as a non-disabled
person so even though that Community
doesn't have a a unified view of it any
voice from a fan who has uh especially a
visible disability their voice should
Trump mine in terms of opinion of if
this is good or bad so take this with a
massive grain of salt but in my view
while the concern much like with the jod
Whitaker costume thing while the concern
is valid and I understand the desire to
address address this I don't think this
was the best approach I think here the
best approach would have been have some
counter examples focus on that give us
that and maybe for the length of your
run retire the character don't use him
you don't have to
don't and maybe he won't my actual gut
instinct to me says he's not intending
to bring davus back he's just doing this
sort of in this way in specifically with
the children in need to try and bring
about something positive and have that
be at least an image of Davos if not the
image of Davos and again I understand
that I'm not entirely sure that the way
he tried to explain it helped it came
across as moneyed at least in terms of
his intentions going
forward I think it revealed a kind heart
and good intention with why he was doing
it but what he does or doesn't do with
the character going forward and that's
super unclear from what he said it's
interpretable in multiple
directions just means that this whole
thing is derailed the the the watching
of this and for all the concern that he
had about derailing the Regeneration
with having David Tenant be in jod
Whitaker's costume um he's he's let this
alteration derail this and I'm sure he
didn't mean for it to but he made kind
of a declarative statement of like I'm
proud of what we did so of all the
nights to make this change I think was
absolutely vital to do this and I'm very
very very proud of the fact that we have
and if he's going to make the decision
I'm glad he's sticking by it I kind of
wish he would have done that with the
what her costume issue make the decision
stand by it
go come on fight me so having it be a
little bit on a little bit different on
different issues um a little
frustrating but the overall thing to
keep in mind is until we know exactly
how or if Davis is going to be used or
depicted again in
future odds
are that ultimately this will not matter
the odds are that this is probably the
only depiction of we're going to get
again if he shows up again I'll talk
about it but this is probably all we're
going to get under um however long Russ
Davis stays with the show this time and
for the purposes within the confines of
a children and needs
special yeah if you're going to have the
character there this was a correct
call I do agree with that but the
discourse has been a
mess cuz it always is the f base
ising
exhausting and ultimately davus is a
character that is worth having a
conversation about as to whether he has
crossed that line I talked about whether
having him around causes more problems
then you get narrative benefit I don't
know if he has that is a conversation
worth having I just can't come to that
conclusion On My Own by myself um and I
don't have an answer right now
I do still
personally feel that counter examples
would have been the better remedy than
potentially undoing the way the
character's been depicted I'm going to
underline potentially because again
within the confines of the special it's
just a shift in time doctor can do that
it's easy I feel like the level of
discourse that got stirred up is in
excess of how important this actually is
but that's also not surprising given
that issues of representation and
disability representation and tropes
that have and are harmful in regards to
that yeah that's again a conversation
worth having but it's exploded out of
just this little thing but uh I'm going
to leave it there what are your thoughts
on any of this please be polite to me to
other commentators to Russell T Davis
whatever your thoughts are agree
disagree like don't like whatever you
feel be
respectful I do delete comments that
aren't but whatever your thoughts are
drop something down in the comments
let's talk about it patreon pays the
bills and enables me to do this as my
living uh even if you can't help me out
that way links down in the description
for other stuff I do like share
subscribe helps me out but what I really
want you to remember is that you are
beautiful you are valid and you are
loved you are the council I'm just
running the meetings and until next time
this council is
adjourned
time to thank some patrons and this time
I'm going to say their names as if I'm
greeting them welcoming them to a party
Robin Moore zumin Lula goddess Salida
Tac the thing that goes don't in the
anime Ruth goer the goeran Oliver B
solitary pictures rri Bogden Melinda
Walters Jen Auntie Kate 808 Becky Sparks
fi likes the poodle Powell t love Tracy
scrapit angry Casper Dave Hall Rosalyn
Bennett have fun tonight and thank you
for your support I don't know why I
decided to do that this time but I don't
know I'm having
[Music]
fun
w